here in this video we will showcase to
you the imax teaser of jurassic world
dominion
and it is just like what we said in our
earlier videos there are the dinos like
morris intrepidus
the giganotosaurus and the quetzalcoas
so we will do this
and we will show you the preview and
then we will talk a little bit
on the dino scene in it so if you're
ready do click the subscribe button to
be a part of the mind cue family
and now let's get down with this
sickness
[Music]
so in the first scene we see a herd of
ankylosaurus near a water hole
and this background is in the late
cretaceous period around 65 to 70
million years ago
ankylosaurus is a genus of armor
dinosaur its forces have been found in
the geological formations dating back to
the very end of the cretaceous period
about 68 to 66 million years ago in
western north america
making it among the last of the
non-avian dinosaurs
these diamonds are not as interesting as
we have seen them in
earlier jurassic world movies so let's
go on to the next one
next in the scene is the quetzalcoatlus
this giant flying lizard is a pterosaur
which is a close relative of the
dinosaurs
and it seems to be in a flock as well
and not as a solitary
individual these are tall mofos maybe a
stall or even taller than giraffes
around 18 to 20 feet tall
and with a wingspan of between 30 to 40
feet as
as per a number of estimates now their
life habit seems to be both
predators and scavengers as they love
semi-aquatic habitats
next we see the morris intrepidus which
seems to be a fair dinosaur
that looks very similar to a real world
velociraptor not the ones from the
movies
it also has peculiar things that were
recently theorized by balan geologists
such as
lips and eyelids the feathers also look
to be
more like thick scrubs of hair rather
than modern day bird feathers
and its lifestyle habit is symbiotic to
the larger giganotosaurus
as it cleans off the meat stuck to the
latter's teeth
much the same way as certain birds and
crocodiles in modern times
we then see an iguanodon grazing about
until it was surprised by the shadow of
an even larger dinosaur
these iguanodons were large bulky
herbivores with features that include
large tom-like spikes
that were possibly used for defense
against predators combined with long
prehensile
fingers able to forage for food in the
grass below
they are around 30 feet long and weigh
around four to five tons
this individual in the preview should
have been food for the giganotosaurus
but for the interruption of the t-rex
now as we have discussed in earlier
videos the giganotosaurus and the t-rex
went all
out on each other although in this imax
release preview
in youtube they didn't show the entire
footage but as we can see the
giganotosaurus was bigger and bulkier
than the t-rex
and had rows of serrated spikes on its
head neck and back
maybe like dorsal plays of godzilla i
might say
and this fight would be the godzilla vs
kong of dinosaurs
another monster fight that we will only
get to see next year
and so with that we come to the end of
this video do hit that like button for
support
and subscribe button as well and don't
forget that bell button for regular
updates on dinos
and monster videos right here on
minecube till the next one
take care fam